the new kids on the block just kicked
off season two up rock this boat on pop
TV now this is the series where the boys
go but Nana's on a cruise ship with
their most rabid female fans and our
senior news editor Jennifer perros is
hanging tough with them today in New
York
we're seeing a lot of ABS this year I
feel like the first season we didn't
teach you many shirts off this season
you guys all you know sometimes we'll
just like hand the baton
Joey will go shirtless once or and we'll
all eat doughnuts and then the next door
be like I can't do it I need protein for
carbs and so one of us will take the
baton and get in shape this season you
see a lot more of the guys mingling with
their diehard fans known as Blockheads
how many people how many cameras how
many hours of downtime 3000 fans us five
and around 20 or so cameras and we just
really went all out to give our side of
the cruise the first season was the fans
experience now we wanted to really share
what it's like right what's been a
craziest fan encounter yet sometimes
when we crowd surf you know they're
holding us up so they sometimes they
grab some there
certain parts go certain places et goes
way back with the band to when they were
teenagers we just want it all to go away
you know it's just we love it Jennifer
moderated a panel discussion between the
band and a group of mommy bloggers today
all of the guys are now in their 40s
Joey's son Griffin is a chip off the new
kid block this is my son Griffin
Ruthie was at the interview but he's got
other career plans Jenny McCarthy is the
first wife to be a part of the cruise
and got a first-hand look at how there
are thousands of other women who are
crazy for her man how she was awesome
because she knows how much the cruise
means to the fans and to us it's just
amazing and it's very special and I'm
glad that she got to see it be a part of
it